QUORUM SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
WE DO.
MR MEDINA IS JUST JOINED US SO
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM FOR WE GET
STARTED WITH A PRESENTATIONS
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
SECRETARY CAN YOU TAKE THAT ROLL
CALL PLEASE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT.
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE.
LACKEY YOUR LACKEY PRESENT
MEDINA.
MEDINA PRESENT QUIRK SILVA SMITH.
SMITH PRESIDENT.
RIGHT WILL GO AHEAD AND DOES
BEGIN WITH MR SALAS FILE ITEM.
FOR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANKS FOR THE MOTION
THANK YOU FOR THE SECOND KEEP
THIS BRIEF -- AB.
NINE SEVENTY ONE WHAT ESTABLISH
CONTRACTOR ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
STATE IT PROJECTS FOR REQUIRE
DEPARTMENTS CONNECT POST
EVALUATION ON A CONTRACTOR'S
PERFORMANCE.
AFTER THE COMPLETED PROJECTS I
THINK MEMBERS YOU GUYS ARE TIRED
JUST LIKE I AM OF SEEING.
HEADLINES LIKE KEEP SHOWING --
THE STATE BEING OVER BUDGET.
BEYOND IT'S TIME AND THIS IS A
BILL TO HELP CORRECT SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT -- I THINK THEY'RE STILL
IN LINE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL.
I HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN MISTER SAUSAGE LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE RIGHT
THANK YOU CAN I GO AHEAD AND
THIS CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY HI MEDINA MEDINA
AYE QUIRK SILVA SMITH SMITH I
OKAY THAT HELL IS OUT THANK YOU
MISTER CELIS.
HELLO WELCOME MISTER GLORIA
PERFECT TIMING THEY HAVE EARLY.
JUST THE NUMBER WE CAN THE FOOD
IS JUST COMMITTEE I WAS LOOKING.
FOR ALRIGHT MR GLORIA THE FILE
ITEM SIX AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
AWESOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- Là AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FOUR AUTHORIZED THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO START THE SALE
PROCESS FOR THE DOWNTOWN SAN
DIEGO STATE BUILDING -- THIS IS
A BUSHEL FOR ME BECAUSE THIS IS
WHEN MY DISTRICT OFFICE IS THAT
THE MORE POINT IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
THE CONSTITUENTS OF SAN DIEGO.
CURRENTLY THE STATE OFFICE --
OCCUPIES.
EFFICIENTLY I WOULD SAY TWO CITY
BLOCKS IN DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO THE
CONDITION OF THE STATE BUILDING
HAS BEEN DETERIORATING FOR YEARS
I KNOW YOU WILL BE SHOCKED TO
FIND OUT WE HAD NOT MAINTAINED
IT.
AS THE BUILDING OUGHT TO BE
MAINTAINED AS BEST THIS IS ON
THE PROPERTY IN MANY THE
OCCUPANTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
HOUSING THE STATE BUILDING HAVE
EXPRESSED THEIR DESIRE TO MOVE
OUT IN FACT MANY HAVE.
TGS HAS LONG HAD IT BEEN
DISPOSED OF SURPLUS STATE
PROPERTY -- WITH PRIORITY GIVEN
THE STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES AND
FINALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SPONSORS LOOKING AT TO FULL CITY
BLOCKS IN DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO
WORK WHICH IS OWNED FOR FORTY
STORY TOWERS WE COULD HOUSE MANY
MANY PEOPLE.
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE IS
MANDATING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO
MORE ABOUT HOUSING IT'S TIME FOR
THE STATE TO WALK THE WALK
DISPOSE OF THIS JUST THIS
PROPERTY.
AND ALLOWED TO HAVE A NEW LIFE
HOPEFULLY AS HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT.
OTHER ADMINISTRATIVE BURKE
HURDLES THAT PREVENTED THIS FROM
HAPPENING TO DATE THIS COMMITTEE
WITH YOUR HI VOTE TODAY WILL
COULD GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE FORWARD.
BRING NEW LIFE TO THE STATE
ASSET PROVIDE MORE HOUSING FOR
COMMUNITY BASICALLY TO CLEAN UP
AND I SORT OUR DISTRICT THAT
DOES NOT REFLECT WELL UPON ANY
OF US WHO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR HAVE A
THE BILL [inaudible]
A IT SAYS IN SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE A QUICK
QUESTION. TO HAVE ANY KIND OF A
A TIME LINE WHEN THE REPORT
IDENTIFIED THE SURPLUS WOULD BE --
RELEASED AND ALL THIS ****
MISTER AKKI THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION AS A PART OF IT
BRINGS US HERE TODAY.
I PRESUME TO GIVE ASSURANCES BY
THE THE DEPARTMENT THAT THAT
REPORT WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN
FEBRUARY ON THERE'S DOWN --
WHICH LIKE TWO MONTHS AGO --
IT'S NOT HERE AND THERE'S NO
CURRENT UPDATE FOR THE TIMELINE
ALL THE MORE REASON FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO EXERCISE
OUR CO EQUAL AUTHORITY UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND GET THIS MOVIE.
SHOWS THE PROBLEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA AT THE
CHECK BECAUSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY HI MEDINA MEDINA
HI KIRK SILVA SMITH SMITH HI.
GREAT THAT MISSION PASSES I'M
AND WILL HOLD UP AND THE ROLE TO
ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH VENTURE.
OKAY MOVING ON TO A FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE MISTER LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
WOULD REQUIRE ANY STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT THAT
EXCEEDS ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
FORM AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
AND DEVELOPING USE RISK
MANAGEMENT PLANS THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE PROJECT ACCORDING
THE LA -- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPENT OVER ONE POINT
TWO BILLION TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS IN THE PAST THREE YEARS
BUT THERE'S OVER SIXTY SEVEN
BILLION.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION WATER RESOURCES.
THE JUDICIARY STATE PARKS
EMERGENCY SERVICES FAILURE TO
MAINTAIN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
HAVE NEGATIVE SHORT AND LONG
TERM IMPACTS OUR ECONOMY.
ADDITIONALLY SAID CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES DEBATE NEW
GENERATIONAL INVESTMENTS IN K.
TWELVE THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES JUDICIAL IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE FACILITIES IN NATURAL
RESOURCE INFRASTRUCTURE
RESULTING FROM CLIMATE CHANGE WE
MUST ENSURE THAT EFFICIENCY AND
COST CONTAINMENT.
MEASURES ARE USED FOR LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT TAX DOLLARS AND
MAINTAIN ON TIME PROJECT
DELIVERY IS AN OPPOSITION MEMBER.
TO THIS MEASURE HI PERCENT LAST
WHEN I HOPE.
BUT THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
IN NINE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT YOU'VE GOT A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
OUR STUFF BASS FERNANDO.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI.
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY HI MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA SMITH
SMITH HI.
AT THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AT THE ROLE OF BEEN FOR AT THE
MEMBER STATES MANAGER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I GREAT I THINK WE CAN MOVE ON
TO ADD.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN MISS SMITH.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO THE D. V.
B. E. PROGRAM IN RESPONSE TO THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN STATE AUDITOR REPORTS
WHICH FOUND AMONG OTHER THINGS.
THE DEPARTMENT'S FAILED TO
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
AND RECORD KEEPING PROTOCOLS ON
CONTRACTS INVOLVING DVDS.
AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE ADDRESSES
THREE CORE ISSUES RAISED IN THE
AUDITS ONE INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF DVB IS PARTICIPATING IN STATE
CONTRACTING. TO ENHANCE TRACKING
AND EVALUATION OF OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES THREE IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY OF PRIME CONTRACTOR
CERTIFICATIONS THAT DVB EASE
HAVE BEEN PAID.
WITH ME TODAY ARE A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I LET THEM
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
[inaudible]
THEY READY.
A MAJOR PART WITHOUT BROOKS
COMPANY CABLE CAR CLEANING.
AND HAVE A SEAT.
I'M AN OWNER OF A DVD OF
MULTIPLE DVD COMPANIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND DIED THIS PROGRAM REALLY
GAVE ME A CHANCE TO GOING TO
SMALL BUSINESS WHEN THERE IS A
HIGH BEARD ENSURING EVERYTHING
ELSE TO LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
HIGH RENTS EVERYTHING'S GOING UP.
BUT THIS PROGRAM ALLOWED ME TO
BUY A BUSINESS.
THAT WAS GOT A FULL BECAUSE THE
THE RETIREE AND WE GOT TO KEEP
ALL THE EMPLOYEES.
WITH LIVING WAGES THEY GOT TO
KEEP THEIR JOBS.
AND I'VE GOT TO PURSUE MY
ENTREPRENEURIAL STE -- ENDEAVORS.
SO THIS PROGRAM IS A IS A REAL
GODSEND.
AND I THINK BY RAISING THIS
OPTION.
IT'LL GIVE CONTRACTING OFFICERS --
MORE STREAMLINED PROCESS TO BE
ABLE.
TO GET BUSINESS TO US AND HELP
US GROW ARE CUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
MY NAME IS -- MANY WANT TO NOW
AS HI MOM.
REPRESENTING THE BORDER THE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ALLIANCE -- I WAS JUST COMBAT
WOUNDED IN VIETNAM.
AND APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
OBVIOUSLY WHY IS RAISING THE DVB
OPTION FROM 252-500-1000.
SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS CAN
HELP ELEVATE DVB HE'S TO PRIME
CONTRACTOR STATUS.
IT'S BEEN WELL WELL SHARED WITH
YOU WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE
[inaudible]
OUR I STARTED A BUSINESS.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE IN
THE DIFFERENCE FROM 200-500-0025
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS TREMENDOUS
NOT ONLY DOES IT HELP LOCAL
ECONOMIES BUT IT HELPS.
CONTINUE TO INSPIRING THOSE
VETERANS THAT TO HAVE GIVEN SO
MUCH.
AND VETERANS.
VETERAN TRAITS AND
CHARACTERISTICS AND RUNNING A
BUSINESS ESPECIALLY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REQUIRES NOT
JUST COMPETITIVE NIGHT
COMPETITIVENESS AND STRUCTURE
BUT CHARACTER.
INTEGRITY AND THEY TEND TO HIRE
MORE VETERANS.
IT'S JUST THE WAY WE ARE.
THESE GUYS ARE I CONSIDER MY
BROTHERS FROM ANOTHER MOTHER
ONLY BECAUSE THEY SERVED.
AND THEY DEDICATED NOT JUST
THEIR LIVES.
AND WE WERE KIND OF LEFT BEHIND
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
STRONG CONSIDERATION OF RAISING
THIS AN ELEVATING US FROM
200-500-0025.
HUNDRED THOUSAND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE THAT.
UP FOR THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AT JACK SMITH FROM FORTUNA BMC --
ALSO BOARD OF THE U. S. AFTER
BUSINESS ALLIANCE -- WE WERE THE
SECOND FASTEST GROWING COMPANY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY THROUGH THE
SUBCONTRACTOR MODEL RAISING THE
TWO FIFTY TO FIVE HUNDRED ALLOWS
COMPANIES LIKE US TO COMPETE.
WITH THE LARGER COMPANIES WE
WENT UP PARTNERING WITH BECAUSE
WE CAN'T COMPETE FOR THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACTS.
WERE NOT LARGE ENOUGH BUT IF YOU
CAN CARVE OUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S ENOUGH
THAT WE CAN DO THE SERVICES WERE
A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY AND SO.
COME THERE'S A LOT OF THE TV'S
ARE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES THAT
ARE REALLY HELP -- ALLOWING THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO SET ASIDE
YOU KNOW TO REALLY KIND OF YOUR
MARK THOSE DOLLARS BECAUSE OF
THEIR MEETING THEIR GOALS -- AND
GETTING THE PROPER SERVICES
WHILE ALLOWING US TO COMPETE
DIRECTLY WITH A LARGE FIRMS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MISS SMITH WOULD YOU LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GIVEN THE SACRIFICES
ALREADY EXPERIENCED BY DVB IS IN
THE POTENTIAL ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THAT THESE CONTRACTS
WOULD PROVIDE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ADDRESS THE CHALLENGE IN
THE D. B. B. E. PROCUREMENT
PROGRAM.
SO WITH THAT I THINK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WE NEED A MOTION
[inaudible]
AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
HI AND THIS BILL DOES ENJOY TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION -- CHECK AT
SECRETARY WOULD LIKE TO CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS
NORTH PETRIE-NORRIS HI
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
LACKING.
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
SMITH SMITH HI.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL HOLD IT
OPEN SAID THAT OTHER MEMBERS CAN
ADD ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
HERE.
I THINK WE ARE NOW WE LOOKING.
RIGHT WERE.
IF WE CAN. FIVE MAKE A COUPLE
CALLS FOR AUTHORS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
GOT IT OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT PERFECT THANK YOU.
IN THE MEANTIME WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND DO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CAN WE GET A MOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEC CHECK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS AB TWO
THIRTY A. B. EIGHT OH TWO AB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX AB. EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT
A. B. SCENE TEN AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FOUR ALL DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS I
PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA
AYE QUIRK SILVA SMITH SMITH BY.
AT THIS BILLS ARE ALL OUT WE
WELL I LEAVE THE ROLE OFFENSE
OTHER MEMBERS CAN OUT ON
THERE
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MR KILEY
[inaudible]
MORNING MANAGER.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THAT.
HI SIR NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT -- EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE THAT HAS -- YOU MADE A LAST
FALL THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION RELEASED THE REPORT
KIND OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
A ROADMAP FOR CALIFORNIA -- THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION REFER TO
THE REPORT IS A CALL TO ACTION.
THAT'S WHY IT IS D. B. FOUR
FIFTY NINE WAS PASSED THE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
STATE GOVERNMENT SERVICES
COMMISSION WITH PUTTING A SET OF
GUIDELINES AND STANDARDS FOR THE
USE OF OUR HOME COLLEGES.
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT NOW
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED ITSELF AS A LEADER
IN A A POLICY IN -- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
MY LET RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF
THE ASILOMAR A AYE PRINCIPLES
SENATE OUTLINED GUIDELINES FOR
THE SAFE AND BENEFICIAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND USE THAT AAI THAT RESOLUTION
ACR TO FIFTEEN WAS ONLY THE
FIRST STEP IN A KNOWLEDGE IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON A CRT
FIFTEEN BY ENSURING THAT FUTURE
USES OF A AYE TOOLS WITHIN --
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT ARE
MANAGED AND IMPLEMENTED IN A
FAIR SECURE APPLE AND BENEFICIAL
MANNER.
THE STANDARD THREE TO EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE FOSTER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PRIORITIZE
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY A
TECHNOLOGIES IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE ACT NOW
TO STAY AHEAD OF THE CURVE AND
BE PREPARED TO RESPONSIBLY
EMBRACE THE FUTURE.
THE BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT
OF PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND I HOPE BY TO HAVE
YOUR EITHER STAY.
WITH ME TODAY IT IS -- BRANDY
NANAK HE WAS WITH THE CITRUS
POLICY.
BUT MY FRIEND SAID THANK YOU
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY MY NAME IS BRANDY NINE
HE I WORK FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AS A DIRECTOR AND
RESEARCHER.
IN AN INTERDISCIPLINARY MULTI
CAMPUS RESEARCH UNIT CITRUS
NUMBER NOT TELL IN CITY OF
CITRUS STANDS FOR THE CENTER FOR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH
IN THE INTEREST OF SOCIETY.
THE VIEWS I'M EXPRESSING TODAY
ON AB FOR FIFTY NINE ARE MY OWN
AND ARE NOT THAT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND GIVE CREDIT TO
THE LAWMAKERS HERE TODAY AND ALL
OF THEM IN OUR STATE LEGISLATURE
WHO VALUE DATA DRIVEN POLICY
MAKING.
THEY IN FACT ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY TO FILL ITS MISSION
AS THE RESEARCH ARM FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
YOUR SUPPORT ENABLES US TO
SUPPORT YOU.
AS YOU GRAPPLE WITH MANY
CHALLENGING ISSUES.
IT IS WELL UNDERSTOOD THE A I
ENABLE DECISION MAKING IS TAKING
ON A MORE CENTRAL ROLE ROLE IN
CORE SOCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS HAVE
MADE THEIR WAY INTO OUR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
COURTHOUSES IN EMPLOYMENT
OFFICES INFLUENCING DECISIONS ON
WHO RECEIVES HEALTH INSURANCE
WHO RECEIVES PAROLE.
IN WHO RECEIVES A JOB OFFER.
WELL THE APPLICATION OF A AYE
ENABLE TOOLS CAN PROVIDE GREAT
GAINS IN EFFICIENCY
EFFECTIVENESS AND EQUITY.
ILL CONSIDERED DESIGNS AND
APPLICATIONS GREAT RISK OF
PERPETUATING INEQUALITY IN
DEEPENING DISPARITIES.
WE ARE AT A PIVOTAL MOMENT.
THE DECISIONS WE MAKE TODAY ON
HOW TO OVERSEE GOVERNMENT USE OF
A I WILL HAVE LONG TERM EFFECTS.
ON WHETHER ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
PROFOUND CHANGES A I WILL BRING.
CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBAL LEADER IN
A AYE HOME TO MANY OF THE
WORLD'S LEADING A AYE COMPANIES
AND RESEARCHERS.
FROM NOT ONLY THE TECHNICAL
FIELDS OF A. I. BUT ALSO THE
SOCIAL SCIENCES AND HUMANITIES
THEY HAVE THOUGHT CRITICALLY
ABOUT THE SOCIAL POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF A I
STRENGTHENING MULTI STAKEHOLDER
COLLABORATION AMONG GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY.
ACADEMIA AND THE PUBLIC IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE WE ARE ABLE
TO HARNESS THE POWER THE EYE IN
WAYS THAT FOSTER ACCOUNTABILITY.
PRIORITIZE SAFETY AND SECURITY
PROTECT PRIVACY AND MONITOR
IMPACTS.
YES I BUSHMAN OF THE EFFORT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
STATE GOVERNMENT SERVICES
COMMISSION THROUGH AB NINE
SEVENTY SIX AND STANDARDS OF
GOVERNMENT USE OF A I OUTLINED
IN AB FOR FIFTY NINE THE FOCUS
OF OUR CONVENIENT TODAY.
ARE IMPORTANT STEPS TO ENSURING
THAT WE COLLABORATIVE LEE MOVE
PRINCIPLES OF RESPONSIBLE A AYE
DEVELOPMENT TO STANDARDS THAT
INFORM SOUND PRACTICES THAT
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT OF A AYE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU I ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE I QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO I HAVE I HAVE A QUESTION I
THINK I'M TRYING TO WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND.
WHY WE NEED TO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL BELL ON TOP OF THAT
SO YOU YOU REFERENCE AB NINE
SEVENTY SIX SO THAT'S A BELL BY
MR CHILD IT'S MAKING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE?
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE VOTED ON A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
AND I THINK UNANIMOUSLY PASSED
[inaudible]
SUIT [inaudible]
WHY?
WOULDN'T YOU JUST KIND OF FOLDER
YOU WANT TO DO AS AN AMENDMENT
INTO THAT BELL RATHER THAN.
REQUIRE REPORTING ON A BILL THAT
HASN'T EVEN BEEN PASSED.
WITH ANOTHER BELL IT JUST SEEMS
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE KIND OF
WRITING A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
LAWS IT'S IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
SUBJECT AND YOU KNOW COULD NOT
AGREE MORE WITH EVERYTHING YOU
SAID.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST
IN THE TOPIC I JUST I'M NOT SURE
WHY WE NEED TO HAVE.
ALL THESE DIFFERENT BILLS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST WRAPPED INTO ONE
THE REALLY GOOD QUESTION AND
BELIEVE ME I'VE ALWAYS AN
ADVOCATE FOR TO SEE.
HER NAILS -- SO -- I'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN WORKING REALLY CLOSE --
WITH THAT WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHALLENGES THAT THE CHAIR OF
PROBLEMS TO GET SOME ACTION ON
THE VICE CHAIR -- ON RIGHT NOW
AND THE JOINT AUTHORED THAT BELT
AND OUT WE DECIDED THAT THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO DO IT -- TO HAVE
HIS BILL WHICH CREATES THE
COMMISSION AND SIX OUT OF
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS -- AND
THEN -- MINE WHICH IS
CONDITIONAL ON THE PASSAGE OF
HIS WHICH ACTUALLY STEPS OUT --
WHAT THE STANDARD -- FOR THE
STATE WHICH WILL BE -- UTILIZED --
BY THIS COMMISSION OF ROCKS IN
OTHER AREAS -- WHEN IT COMES TO
THE USE OF A ON?
LIKE YOU KNOW FOSTER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IN THAT YOU
WOULD RESPONSIBILITY -- FOR FOR
SORRY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE USE
THAT IMPACTED A AYE TOOLS AN
APPEALS PROCESS -- RECORDING AND
MONITORING GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT
USED TODAY I OKAY.
SUIT I'M IT'S PRETTY UNUSUAL FOR
A PIECE OF LEGISLATION BE
CONTINGENT ON THE PASSAGE OF
ANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
THAT [inaudible]
ACCURATE -- I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
JUST REAL QUICKLY WITH ALEXIS.
TELL ME TO VOTE YES ON THIS --
WELL.
IF SHE DOES I THINK WE OUGHT TO
HAVE SOME -- MEANS -- TO TO AT
LEAST MONITOR THE PROCESS SO.
I'M NOT GONNA TRY TO STOP THE
BELL I HAD A NEW ADDED A NON
RECOMMENDATION SO I'M GONNA BE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BUT IF.
YOU OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PENNY
THINK IT SIMPLY BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID I DON'T THINK IT NEEDS TO
BE A SEPARATE BILL I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IT.
FOLD INTO THE EXISTING BELL --
BUT IF OTHER MEMBERS ARE
SUPPORTIVE THEN.
THAT IS FINE IS WALDRON CONCERT
IF.
IF IT IS THEY SEE FIT SO.
I'M.
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLASS.
AFTER I APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW
THE POINTS RAISED BY THE CHAIR --
AND I'M CERTAINLY OPEN TO THE
WORKING TO ADVANCE -- THE POLICY
IN WHATEVER FORM IS BEST I DO
THINK THAT -- BY MOVING THIS
ALONG TODAY WILL FACILITATE SO I
ASKED.
FOR THANKS.
ALL RIGHT I'M SECRETARY FOR LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL I WE I THINK WE
NEED A MOTION.
WITH THE BILL.
RIGHT CHAIR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
SMITH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER KILEY
OKAY MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
NUMBER -- FIVE WITH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB TEN TWENTY
SIX TO ESTABLISH A STATE HOUSING
AGENCY WITH THE CABINET LEVEL
SECRETARY CHARGED WITH
OVERSEEING ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
HOUSING.
CURRENTLY THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERSIGHT OF
NUMEROUS DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING
THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT HOWEVER
THE LEADING DEPARTMENT REQUIRING
THE MOST RESOURCES IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WHICH CONSISTS OF MORE THAN FOR
FORTY BUREAUS BOARDS COMMITTEES
COMMISSIONS AND OTHER ENTITIES.
A NEW HOUSING AGENCY WOULD HELP
FOCUS THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT HOUSING
SUPPLY CRISIS WITH ME TODAY IS
JENNIFER SPEC FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
BUT I'M SURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT STAKE WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S DEDICATION TO
HELPING US WITH A HOUSING SUPPLY --
IS CLEAR BASED UPON RECENT THE
RECENT ELECTION OF THE NEED FOR
ADEQUATE STABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
PARTISAN COPPER CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILIES.
THE EXPENDITURE UP ON HOUSING IS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL COMMITMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEY UNDERTAKE
THAT IN THEIR DAY TO DAY LIVES
FOR THE MORE HOUSING AND HOUSING
RELATED ACTIVITIES ARE PRIMARY
IMPORTANCE TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE.
AND IT WARRANTS A CLEAR AND
UNIFIED FOCUS FROM STATE
GOVERNMENT AND THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION WITHIN OUR AGENCY
STRUCTURE.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DEFENDER AFTER CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS JUST SITTING THERE
HOUSING CRISIS CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF OUR TOP IF YOU WERE GONNA
MAKE SENSE TO HAVE THIS IS OUR
REMAIN CONSUMERS OR THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SPORTS SCENE
NINE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THE YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PLACE --
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU.
I THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HI BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY HI MEDINA MEDINA
HI KIRK SILVA.
SMITH.
WE WILL PUT THAT FELL ON CALL TO
NAVAL OTHER MEMBERS DATA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
WELL
AS OF HELLO MISTER OBERNOLTE.
WE ARE WE ARE READY FOR YOU
MOVING ON TO FILE NUMBER EIGHT
MR OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE IMPORTANCE THAT
SMALL BUSINESSES PLAY.
THE AND THE ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
EMPLOY OVER FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
OVER HALF OF EMPLOYEES AND
CALIFORNIA WORK FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
OVER HALF OF THE JOB GROWTH IN
THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS WILL BE
ATTRIBUTABLE TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
HOWEVER SMALL BUSINESSES OFTEN
STRUGGLE IN CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT LARGE
COMPANIES CAN AFFORD TO EMPLOY A
FULL TIME PEOPLE WHO JUST DEAL
WITH COMPLIANCE WITH LAWS WERE
SMALL BUSINESSES.
REALLY HAVE TO PLAY MULTIPLE
ROLES AND DON'T HAVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE AWARE OF ALL THE REGULATIONS
SOMETIMES THAT AFFECT THEM.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE IS A SMALL
EFFORT TO COMBAT THIS PROBLEM.
IN RESEARCHING THIS BILL I'VE
COME ACROSS SOME REALLY
HORRIFYING TALES.
OF WAYS IN WHICH BUSINESSES HAS
BEEN HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED BY
CALIFORNIA'S REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE
OF ONE I TALKED TO A WOMAN IN
VACAVILLE.
WHO?
REALIZED HER DREAM OF OPENING
HER OWN RESTAURANT IN IT AND SHE
OPENED IT IT ON HISTORIC
BUILDING OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
OLD.
I SHE WAS SUBJECT TO A
INSPECTION BY SEVERAL DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES THEY DIDN'T FIND
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE SAFETY OF
HER FOOD PREPARATION BUT THEY
DID FIND A NUMBER.
OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE BUSINESS
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT SHE WAS
LOCATED IN THIS HUNDRED YEAR OLD
BUILDING THE SHOOTER FINES
TOTALING ELEVEN THE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AND IT WILL GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT ONE OF THE FINES WAS -- FOR
MISSING A PLASTIC CAP ON AN
ELECTRIC OUTLET THAT FINE WAS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS AND SHE
WHEN SHE TALKED TO ME SHE WAS IN
TEARS SHE SAID.
IF THEY HAD JUST TOLD ME THAT I
NEEDED TO PUT A 25%.
SEND COVER ON THIS ELECTRIC
OUTLET I WOULD HAVE GLADLY DONE
IT BUT SHE DIDN'T HAVE ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF EXCESS
CAPITAL SHE WAS -- SHE WAS
FORCED TO CLOSE HER BUSINESS AND
IN FACT THE FIVE BUSINESSES IN
BACK OF ALL THAT WORKS INSPECTED
THAT DAY ALL FIVE OF THEM WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS SO.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE WOULD
PERMIT NOT REQUIRED BUT PERMIT
STATE AGENCIES THE DISCRETION.
TO REDUCE OUR MEDICAID FINDS IN
APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THOSE APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE VERY NARROWLY TAILORED --
ONLY IN CASES WHERE THE BUSINESS
WAS A FIRST TIME VIOLATOR --
ONLY IN CASES WHEN THE BUSINESS
OF THE VIOLATION WAS INADVERTENT
THE BUSINESS COOPERATED WITH THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE VIOLATION
WAS CORRECTED ONLY THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD GIVE THE
AGENCIES THE DISCRETION TO LOWER
THOSE FINES BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
MANY OF THOSE FINES ARE FIXED IN
STATUTE.
THE AGENCY IS DOING THE
INSPECTION ONCE THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED THE VIOLATIONS
OCCURRED THEY HAVE NO DISCRETION
IN SETTING THE FINES.
SO I THINK THIS IS BEING GREAT
THING TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
FLOURISH IN CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE
JEFF WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
YES -- GOOD MORNING -- ROB WHICH
YOU FOR THE CAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE AS A JOB
CREATOR -- EXCUSE ME AZIZ
ELEMENT TO STATE THE YOU KNOW
THAT WE REALLY DO THIS IS
INVESTING CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE
RIGHT SMALL BUSINESS ARE THE
ENGINE OF GROWTH THEY ACCOUNT
FOR MOST OF THE JOB GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE NEW TO THE GAME YOU KNOW
AND HAVE HUGE PROMISE BUT TO SIT
TO SHUT THEM DOWN FOR MISTAKES
WHICH YEAH IT'S LIKE INTENSELY
THINK.
ENDING A CHILD RIGHT THE CHILLS
LEARNING IS IMPROVING IS GROWING
AND YOU WANT THAT OPTION TO GROW
SO WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT --
AND I WILL PROVIDE -- ONE THE
ONE OF THE POINT LIKE TO ADD IS
THAT REALLY USES THE NATIONAL
CONTINUATION OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS LIAISON Là WHICH WE
ALREADY HAVE ON THE BOOKS WHICH
CONNECTS SMALL BUSINESSES RIGHT
TO HELP THEM.
TAKE THE STEP EIGHTY TAKE THIS
ALLOWS THE FINANCIAL COMPONENT
THAT SAME SUPPORT TO GO FORWARD
WE WILL RELIEVE YOU IS A
CONTINUATION OF THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
KIND OF A SMALLISH YEAH
COMMITTEE ROOMS MAYBE WE'LL DO A
LITTLE MUSICAL CHAIRS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WERE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL --
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BILL.
THAT THIS BILL ALLOWS BUSINESSES
THAT ARE CAUGHT VIOLATING THE
LAW. TO OBEY FINES AND PENALTIES
FOR VIOLATING HEALTH SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS.
REVIEW THIS BILL IS OVERLY BROAD
FOR WANTED TO FIND SMALL
BUSINESSES AS ANY COMPANY WITH A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR LESS THAT
ENCOMPASSES 97% CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS -- WHICH IS
OBVIOUS THE HUGE SCOPE -- IT
ALSO APPLIES TO WEAR IT ALSO
APPLIES TO EVERY STATE AGENCY
DEPARTMENT COMMISSION SORENESS
OVER SO THAT WOULD MEAN THAT CAL
EPA WOULD -- WOULD HAVE WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO REDUCE PENALTIES FOR
COMPANIES VIOLATING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS THE AT
THE AGE REDUCE PENALTIES FOR
COMPANIES THAT ARE ENGAGED TO
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION D. I.
R. FOR COMPANIES THAT ARE
ENGAGED DISTILLING WAGES FOR
WORKERS.
CAL OSHA FOR COMPANIES THAT ARE
ENGAGED IN -- FOR COMPANIES THAT
BYERLY WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTION SO THE SCOPE OF THIS
IS REALLY REALLY BROUGHT IT ALSO
SHIELD SOME OF THE WORST
VIOLATORS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IS
MADE UP OF SMALL BUSINESSES SO
INDUSTRIES LIKE CONSTRUCTION
JANITORIAL AG MOST OF THESE
COMPANIES HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF WORKPLACE
VIOLATIONS INSTEAD CALIFORNIA.
THAT THAT'S WHY THIS YEAR A CLUB
BUILDING TRADES SEIU --
TEAMSTERS A HOST OF BUSINESS A
HOST OF WORK ORGANIZATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ARE ALL
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL -- IT
ALSO DISINCENTIVE EYES IS
COMPLIANCE WITH -- WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS SO -- CREATING A
SYSTEM WHERE COMPANIES CAN FIRST
IGNORE THE LAW AND THEN IF THEY
ARE CAUGHT VIOLATING THE LAW CAN
BE IMMUNE FROM PENALTIES FOR
THAT VIOLATION.
IS AND A RIDICULOUS SYSTEM SAID
TO CREATE -- IT ALSO -- IT IT
MAKES NOT ONLY WORKERS BUT THE
PUBLIC LESS SAFE AND ALSO --
IT'S UNCLEAR TO BUSINESSES WERE
FOLLOWING THE RULES OF THE
BUSINESSES WHO HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING RIGHT AND ARE
FOLLOWING THE RULES ARE UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE FOR THESE COMPANIES
WHO CAN GET IMMUNITY FOR
VIOLATING THE LAW SO FOR THESE
REASONS WERE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU SUSKIND CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
AS WELL AN ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MISTER YOUNG -- THE CNA DOES NOT
BELIEVE IT'S CLEAR IT THAT ANY
ENTITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO ESCAPE
PROPERLY IMPLY IMPOSED CIVIL
PENALTIES. FOR VIOLATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA LAWS MISTER YOUNG
STATED IT ALLOWS FOR ONE FREE
BITE OF THE APPLE WE DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE APPROACH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
DOES TAKE A COUPLE SECONDS AND
SAY JUST A COUPLE QUICK A BRIEF
REMARKS FIRST OF ALL.
MANY CITY AGENCIES ALREADY HAVE
A PROCESS.
FOR DEALING SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
THINK AS A BUSINESS OWNER YOU
MAY HAVE BEEN -- NEXT TO OR HELD
LIABLE FOR SOMETHING THAT YOU
SHOULDN'T BE FOR EXAMPLE THE CAL
OSHA.
PROCESS AS THE CAL OSHA APPEALS
BOARD.
BROUGH FINES AND PENALTIES ARE
ROUTINELY LOWERED -- IN THAT
ARENA OTHER SEVERAL OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIE OTHER AGENTS AS
WELL SECONDLY THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY IN THE STATE IS A VAST
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOLKS LIKE MICHAEL
AND I NEED TO BE HERE TO
LEGISLATE IN PASS REGULATIONS
AND PASS LAWS FOR THE VAST
NUMBER OF BUSINESSES THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THAT DON'T
PLAY BY THE RULES.
THAT ARE GOING TO IGNORE NO
MATTER WHAT.
WHAT THEY DO AND AS A COST OF
DOING BUSINESS?
RIGHT THAT INTO THEIR BOTTOM
LINE THEY'LL PAY A PENALTY IF IF
THEY GET CAUGHT -- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THERE ARE SOME
GOOD BUSINESSES THAT MIGHT GET
CAUGHT UP USING THE TROUBLE
OBERNOLTE EXAMPLE.
IN SITUATIONS THAT THEY MADE AN
HONEST MISTAKE BUT WE CAN'T --
FORGET ABOUT THE VAST
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THAT IT
EXISTS IN THE STATE FULL OF BAD
EMPLOYERS AND FINALLY ALL SAY --
I CAN SPEAK MOST CULTURALLY
ABOUT CAL OSHA.
A CAL OSHA STAFF WHEN WE DO
REGULATIONS A CAL OSHA THEY ARE
ALSO THE SAME STAFFERS THERE IN
THE FIELD.
DOING INSPECTIONS SO.
SO.
TAKING MORE OF THEIR TIME OUT OF
THEIR WORK DAY TO TALK TO
EMPLOYERS ABOUT WHETHER THEY
MEANT TO MAKE A MISTAKE WHETHER
THEY DIDN'T NEED TO MAKE A
MISTAKE.
AND FIGURING OUT.
WHAT IT MEANS IN THEIR MIND?
WELL WHETHER THEY SHOULD GET --
NEXT FOR A FINE OR NOT TAKES
THAT VITAL STEP AWAY FROM I'M
DOING THE WORK THEY NEED TO DO
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
MAKING SURE BAD EMPLOYERS ARE
HELD TO ACCOUNT.
SO THAT GOOD EMPLOYERS DON'T
HAVE TO COMPETE.
ON A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD -- TO
TO MAKE TO MAKE A LIVING THE
STATE SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS
IN THE ONCE PREVIOUSLY STATED
WERE OPPOSED THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARE A PART OF SCO YOU
CALIFORNIA JUST A REAL QUICKLY
IN THE JANITORIAL SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY WE DEAL WITH BAD ACTORS
ALL THE TIME SO THESE ARE
BUSINESSES.
THEY KNOW HOW TO VIOLATE THE LAW
THE KNOW HOW TO WORK THE RULES I
CAN JUST IMAGINE IN THIS
SITUATION WHERE THEY WOULD
CHANGE.
BUSINESS ENTITY ALL THE TIME TO
GET A FREEBIE ON VIOLATIONS ALL
THE TIME I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY DURABLE I
THINK SOME OF THE WORST BUSINESS
IN THE STATE WILL.
DEFINITELY UTILIZE THAT OPTION
SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE OPPOSE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
I ARE THERE QUESTIONS SORRY
SOMEONE ELSE HERE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS QUIRK SILVA.
OUR I EIGHT MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD BECAUSE OF NOT ONLY THE
MANY BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
APPROACHED ME.
UP HERE -- IN THE STATE BUT ALSO
IN MY DISTRICT JUST OVER SPRING
BREAK I HAD ABOUT TWELVE
BUSINESSES VERY SMALL THAT CAME
IN TO SPEAK TO US ABOUT SOME OF
THESE EXAMPLES.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO OUR
TO LABOR FRIENDS I UNDERSTAND --
THAT WE DO HAVE THE BATTLE PULLS
IN WHETHER IT'S IN TEACHING OR
CORPORATIONS OR THE MEDICAL
FIELD THERE'S ALWAYS A BAD
CHARACTER.
ON BUT I THINK THAT -- WHEN WE
WORK TOWARDS THE HIGHEST LEVEL
INSTEAD OF THE LOWEST LEVEL WE
BRING EVERYBODY UP IN ONE OF THE
THINGS AND WE START TO LOOK AT --
LABOR AND EMPLOYERS IT'S GOT TO
BE A BALANCE THERE'S GOT TO BE A
BALANCE WITH EMPLOYER.
AND EMPLOYEE AND WE WANT THEM
ALL TO RISE AND LIKE I SAID.
A NINETY FOUR YEAR OLD.
RESTAURANT OWNER IN FULLERTON --
EDDIE SHELDRICK WHO OWNS -- THE
POLIS PIES AND FULLER.
TEN II HE SAID YOU KNOW HE HAD A
VIOLATION BECAUSE HE'S ONE OF
THE EMPLOYEES DIDN'T WEAR THE
RIGHT SHOES AND THAT AND ONCE
THAT START IT BECOMES LIKE A
SNOWBALL EFFECT WHERE.
YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO SETTLE AND
THE YOU KNOW THEN THAT BECOMES
OTHERS THAT ARE MAKING THE SAME
CLAIMS.
AND IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING TO
SUPPORT OUR BUSINESSES AS BEEN
SAID MANY TIMES WHY DO THEY WANT
TO DO BUSINESS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I JUST FEEL THAT WERE AT THE
TIPPING POINT OF IF LESS WE CAN
HAVE THAT SUPPORT OF EMPLOYEE
AND EMPLOYER -- WE'RE GOING TO
KIND OF PUSH PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
BUSINESSES AND THAT DOES NOT
MEAN I DON'T RESPECT.
THE WORKERS RIGHTS AND SAFETY
AND ALL THOSE BY AYE THIS THIS
IS A BILL I CAN'T SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THIS MESSAGE.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
NO I PREVIOUSLY IN JEDI MOVED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE -- AND ALL
TO BE GETS IS CONSISTENT DO SO
AGAIN TODAY I DO THINK OUR
FRIENDS IN THE LABOR COMMITTEE
RAISE SOME SOME FAIR INVALID
POINTS THAT PERHAPS WE DO NEED
TO ADDRESS I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD -- I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT YOU KNOW THE BAD
ACTORS AND IT'S VERY HARD TO
LEGISLATE AROUND THOSE SPECIFIC
SET OF FOLKS BUT I'M NOT UNLIKE
MY COLLEAGUE I FIND CONSISTENTLY
IN MY DISTRICT THAT FOLKS ARE
SAYING.
THE REGULATORY BURDENS AND THE
ABILITY JUST TO DEAL WITH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS HAVE BECOME
SO CUMBERSOME THAT THE
CHALLENGES OF BEING A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER ARE ALMOST TOO
MUCH FOR SO MANY PEOPLE AND WE
KNOW.
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE EMPLOYED IN
OUR SMALL BUSINESS SECTOR ACROSS
THE STATE SO AGAIN TO BE
CONSISTENT MAY GO AHEAD SUPPORT
THE MEASURE TODAY I'M HOPEFUL
THAT AS WE MOVE ALONG OUR
FRIENDS CONCERNS -- FROM LABOR
CAN BE ACCOMMODATED IN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS THAT
THANK YOU.
MR LACKEY YEAH I JUST WONDER
REAL QUICKLY ADDRESS THE
ACCUSATION THAT THIS BILL --
WOULD SHIELD THAT ACTORS AND I
DO NOT BELIEVE IN ANY.
WAY SHAPE OR FORM THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE A DISCRETIONARY BILL LIKE
THIS.
THAT -- THAT IS VERY LIKELY TO
HER AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THAT YOUR CLOTHES I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
SO AB I WOULD ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO BUILDING
THRIVING COMMUNITIES TO CREATING
GOOD JOBS. FIVE IN BUILDING
STRONG CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
I THINK ALL OF US I THINK
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PROTECTING BAD ACTORS AND THAT.
HI BUT THAT WE'RE WRITING
POLICIES AND ESTABLISHING LIES
THAT.
ENABLED THE GOOD BUSINESSES TO
THRIVE -- AND HELP WITH THAT FOR
ME WHILE I ABSOLUTELY HERE AND
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION FOR ME.
I'M I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT I
THINK HAS BEEN.
A VERY STRONG EFFORT ON YOUR
PART TO KEEP THIS AS YOU SAID
VERY NARROWLY FOCUSED AND JUST
LOOKING AT THAT THE BILL
LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW SO IT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS.
THE VIOLATION BY THE SMALL
BUSINESS BUSINESS DID NOT POSE
AN IMMINENT HEALTH SAFETY OR
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT.
I AM SO WELL I THINK WE DO NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
LOOSENING UP REGULATIONS TO
MATCH WE ALSO HAVE TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE.
GOOD SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS CAN
THRIVE BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO CREATE
GOOD JOBS FOR CALIFORNIA AS YOU
SAID. 97% OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS
ARE WORKING FOR COMPANIES THAT
ARE HARD TO FIND A SMALL
BUSINESSES.
I'M.
TO I WOULD ASO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS AND THAT I
WOULD HOPE THAT AS THIS BILL
MOVES THROUGH THAT YOU CONTINUE.
TO ENGAGE WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS AND I THINK.
ALLEVIATE THE FEAR THAT THIS IS
KIND OF AN END RUN ON AND
WORKERS RIGHTS ARE AROUND
WORKERS PROTECTIONS BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY DON'T SEE IT THAT WAY
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD NOT BE
SUPPORTING IT.
IF I DID BUT AT TODAY I I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS ABOUT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I WILL
TALK ABOUT THE ASSERTION THAT
PERHAPS THIS MIGHT WEEKEND.
WORKERS RIGHTS OR WORKER SAFETY.
WE WERE VERY CAREFUL WHEN WE
CRAFTED THE LANGUAGE IN THIS
BILL TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE THE CASE STORE --
IT AND WE ALSO I ABSOLUTELY DO
NOT WANT TO PROVIDE A SHIELD FOR
A BAD ACTOR AND I I HOPE THAT
WE'VE DONE THAT BECAUSE THE BILL
SAYS THAT THE VIOLATION FIRST OF
ALL HAS TO BE IN A BURDEN SO IF
IT WAS A WILLFUL VIOLATION.
WAS COMPANIES WOULD NOT QUALIFY
I SAYS THAT THEY HAVE TO BE A
FIRST TIME VIOLATORS SO IF
YOU'RE ONE OF THESE BAD ACTORS
THAT IS.
A SUFFERING REPEAT VIOLATIONS
YOU WOULD NOT QUALIFY ALSO IT'S
DISCRETIONARY SO DOES WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT ANY DEPARTMENT MUST
REDUCE OR MITIGATE THE FIGHTS
WE'RE JUST GIVING THEM.
THE POWER TO REDUCE OR MITIGATE
THE FINES IN APPROPRIATE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE'RE TRUSTING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
COURSE OF THEIR INVESTIGATION
WOULD DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THESE VIOLATIONS WERE MINOR
DIDN'T IMPACT THE SAFETY OF THE
WORKERS WERE INADVERTENT.
AND ONLY IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
TAKE THAT THE STEP OF OF
REDUCING OUR MITIGATING THE
PENALTY.
SO I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION SHOULD THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD IN PARTICULAR THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD.
THE THE CONCERN THAT PERHAPS
IT'S TO BROADEN THE DEFINITION
OF SMALL BUSINESS HAPPY TO LOOK
AT THAT MAYBE A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES IS NOT THE RIGHT
NUMBER MAYBE THE NUMBER SHOULD
BE LOWER SO -- SHOULD THE BILL
MOVED TO APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S A
DISCUSSION THAT I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE AND I'M ALSO MY MY DOORS
ALWAYS OPEN.
IF ANYONE HAS SUGGESTIONS ABOUT
HOW TO TIGHTEN UP THE LANGUAGE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BAD ACTORS
DON'T SLIP THROUGH.
BUT I WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
CORRECT WE'VE GOT A MOTION AND A
SECOND SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I LACKEY LACKEY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA.
SMITH SMITH HI.
RIGHT THAT BELL IS OUT AND WILL
LEAVE AT THE ROLE OF BEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON IN A VENTURE.
SEARCH WITHOUT THE WORK ON
AND
OKAY I'M.
THERE.
WE'RE DONE WITH THE BELL
PRESENTATIONS FOR THIS COMMITTEE
WHAT WILL WILL DO IS GO AHEAD
AND HAVE.
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN TO ENABLE
MEMBERS WERE MISSING TO ADD ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PATTERSON --
SEN I BURKE.
BURKE I QUIRK SILVA.
AB FOR FIFTY NINE BURKE.
BURKE AYE QUIRK SILVA SMITH
[inaudible]
SMITH I AB NINE SEVENTY ONE
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE HI.
PATTERSON.
AYE QUIRK SILVA.
AB AB.
NINE SEVENTY ONE NO THIS IS ALL
US.
OKAY A CONTRACT.
TO AB TEN TWENTY BURKE.
BURKE I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH SMITH I
YEAH.
AB. NINE SEVENTY ONE SALAS
[inaudible]
SORRY. FOR A. B. FOUR FIVE NINE
BURKE.
BOOK OF BURKE BURKE NOT LOADING
SORRY [inaudible]
IT'S OKAY.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I KIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
SEVEN FIVE AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
OF PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
AB FOR FIFTY NINE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I AB NINE SEVENTY
ONE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I AND CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR KIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIGHT I BELIEVE
THAT IS EVERYTHING YES OKAY
GREAT WE ARE ADJOURNED